ومعنا من حيث جوني منصور الخبير بالشؤون
الاسرائيليه طبعا هنالك استنفار استاذ
جوني في الجانب الاسرائيلي خشيه ان يكون
هذه العمليه مستمره او هنالك
اشخاص اخرون لكن لاي مدى يمثل ما جرى صدمه
للجانب الاسرائيلي لا سيما في هذا الجانب
من الحدود المشهود له بالهدوء هذه الجبل
هادئه
نعم هناك يعني المسار الامني الذي تتمسك
به اسرائيل بالنسبه للحدود التي تمتد على
يعني مسافه ما يقارب الميتين كيلو متر بين
الطرف الغربي الجنوب الغربي لقطاع غزه
وبين
الخليج العقبه واسرائيل كانت قد مدت
جدارا عازلا فاصلا مراقب بشكل 24 على سبعه
ايام يعني بشكل دائم ومستمر الى جانب
التنسيق الامني بين اسرائيل وبين مصر فحدث
ما حدث اليوم هذا على المسار الامني لان
اسرائيل كل حدث من هذا النوع قبل ان تحقق
به وقبل ان تبدا
بجسس النبض سواء كان السياسي او العسكري
تعلن انه حدث امني لكن قد يتبين نحن اليوم
يعني هو يوم سبت المؤسسه الاسرائيليه سواء
كانت سياسيه والعسكريه يعني تعمل رسميا
لكن هي تعمل الان بصمت في الخفاء لتطبيق
هذا الحادث وبالتالي الاعلان عنه انه حادث
يتعلق بجانب جنائي بمعنى انه هناك محاولات
لتهريب اما مخدرات او بضائع وما اشبه ذلك
وحتى ايضا يمكن ان يكون الحدث انه علاقه
ايضا
بتهريب
يعني
لا تقول جنائي الروايه تتحدث عنها حادث
امني خطير حاجه حتى الان حدد لكن الان
المسار هذا المسار المقابل ذلك وبالتوازي
معه يعمل المسار السياسي بشكل مكثف بين
اسرائيل وبين مصر لتطويق هذا الحادث لي
والاعلان عنه في نهايه المطاف على انه ليس
حادثه امنيا بقدر ما هو حادث يعني له
علاقه بالجانب الجنائي هذا ما اتوقعه انه
ليس حادثا امنيا
الى اي مدى يمثل ما جرى صدمه للجانب
الاسرائيلي
الجانب المصري خاصه على نتحدث عن جندي
بشكل منفرد او مجموعه من الجنود منفردين
موجودين في منطقه نائيه مثل هذه المنطقه
يقومون بهذا العمل قد تقول
اي فرضيه لجنود